number one buddy now we're never this is
it yeah we cross the finish line with
that song and I'm so thankful for that
when we are here at Christmas yeah
and we were talking about the song and
the new record coming out on January 1st
we felt we had something special but
could we take it to this next level and
we did and the fans have spoken and
we're just riding this wave right now
and it feels great
so how hungover were you New Year's Day
when when you released it to the whole
world on a scale of one to ten a good
night you're also sharing your life with
your fans you got the new video she
drives me crazy that's right
was it like having your family on set
shooting a video I thought it was really
cool this was an all-female cast like
95% female crew yeah so Cecelia and I
wanted this great female energy to
surround our daughter so that they can
see that even though you can be in front
of the camera there are so many
incredible things that happen behind the
camera and great lessons to learn in
arts and entertainment and in people who
just want to work hard yeah so these
incredible women who are part of this
video added so much for the entire day
it's a day that I will you know never
forget and always remember for my little
kids
you know we know that you've don't had
person to fatherhood three kids out is
that the magic number
you're gonna do four is more I was
complete after Mila and then I was even
more complete after Aria and then even
more complete now that leo is a part of
our family right so if we're blessed
with another child I think that that
would be an incredible thing for our
entire family if this is all we're
blessed with we were the happiest family
in the world
oh so it really doesn't matter to me
either way
[Music]